[Musique]
why versailles pour que versailles et il
le berceau de la french touch c'est ce
que va tenter d'expliquer ce
documentaire fiction réalisé par marco
l'ennui même aussi musicien il est venu
le présenter à la presse et aux élus
versailles et au palais des congrès de
la commune et étienne et précis
blackstrobe
en euros bottini et moi même non plus
voilà donc c'est un peu c'est leur
histoire comment on est passé en fait de
deux lycéens à versailles et pourquoi
pourquoi en fait toute cette scène
french touch finalement a éclos à
versailles
la réponse se trouve peut-être dans la
cour d'école du lycée jules ferry où se
sont côtoyés bon nombre de ces musiciens
devenus pour la plupart tous célèbres
d'une durée d'une heure dix ce film a
composé de deux parties la fiction une
jeune journaliste qui veut écrire un
papier sur la french touch et de l'autre
de nombreuses images d'archivés
en gros travail pour le réalisateur il
ya tout ce qui est avant le succès entre
guillemets c'est à dire les premiers
groupes de lycée quand on commence
surtout dans les années 80 où il n'y a
pas encore de téléphone qui fit
n'apparaissait gap à tout ça et deuxième
partie où là bas on tousse on a fait des
clips et puis les émissions de télé et
puis après voilà ça devient phoenix et
c'est une même image quoi
versailles ville de création les élus en
sont fiers et veulent encourager tous
types de courants musicaux versailles un
speaker je crois versailles moi j'ai eu
beaucoup plus c'est la qualité
c'est en cherche une forme d'excellence
et ce mille maux de la french touch
pourquoi free jazz c'est parce que là
tout simplement c'est vous montiez
vraiment porté que je suis important
l'avant-première de why versailles aura
lieu le 17 février dans le cadre du
festival fame à la gaîté lyrique à paris
pour les versailles et une soirée sera
organisée fin février également au
palais des congrès de la ville